[Applause]
hello
nice to have you with us thank you it's
nice to be here i thought i was a tv
redhead and you are just completely
kicking my ass right now
beautiful hair but you're a real redhead
aren't you well yeah
yeah i'm not oh you're not no okay i'm a
blonde
oh there you go you just decided so this
is something that you decided at one
point i want to be red and you just
stuck with it yeah
i i i had been sort of toying with it
and then when i got cast in sex in the
city
they decided three blondes would
probably be too much so
right which looks great it looks
fantastic i'm gonna start actually
getting mine that color
yeah i'm gonna start changing it so that
it you know every night so that people
tune in just to see it this way too
you're gonna grow it long and
dreadlocks i want dreadlocks to be good
on you somebody would just pop
now the last name nixon nixon i would
think it's not the easiest
last name i i was mocked for my first
name obviously but yes
hard hard last name i think to have
probably in the early 70s
at the time exactly when i grew up um
yeah in 1973
naaman nixon you can't even mention your
name without somebody
cracking a joke and my mother always
said you know
i i that she grew up in the 40s with a
father named adolph
and then she lived through the 70s with
a husband named nixon she just
couldn't escape adolf nixon but now
that would be a great if i got adolf
nixon for congress
right you can trust me yeah but you know
it would be great but now nobody even
remembers nixon no one
can even remember how to spell my name
anymore wait a minute no they don't know
that
they say i say you know you know what's
your last name nixon is that
n-i-c-k-s-o-n
what out of sight out of mind well i
think a lot of kids today they don't
even
anything before like the a-team they
don't know
yeah you know i've noticed when i'm
talking to kids you're like jimmy carter
whoa what's that
like it was a movie forget about it
don't worry about it
this is a very uh and i mean this in the
best of ways it's an ex
no don't be afraid be afraid uh no it's
a sexually explicit show that you do and
i think that's what a lot of people like
about it's very honest
it can you can go further than a lot of
network shows
is there ever anything that they took
out because it went too far
occasionally we do go too far and we
even stop ourselves yes there was one
there was one time actually one of my
favorite things that i've ever
filmed i was having sex with this
character who played a detective who was
like this gorgeous guy that i felt very
overwhelmed to be going out with because
he was so attractive and i got a little
drunk during our date because i was so
nervous and then we were actually having
sex and this is the part that they cut
we're having sex and i've drunk too much
and i throw up all over him
ooh and it was so skillfully done by our
prop department too because it was
projectile
so they shot it from over here and they
had a hose and i would just go
and dinty moore beef stew would come
shooting out on my mouth
[Applause]
well first of all some guys are into
that and second
the poor did you throw up on me
um the poor actor that i was acting with
was not it was like five
in the morning you know the smell of the
beef stew he thought he'd signed on to
do some
sexy show that's also yeah he he
probably reads the script his agent says
you know you're gonna have a sex scene
with cynthia nixon he's like great and
they probably didn't tell him
beef stew yeah shot at you at 40 miles
an hour no
when i see in movies when people have to
vomit and they have the hose running up
the side they always turn exactly
profile
and then someone offstage hits a plunger
and vomit comes out
i've always thought i'd love to get
rigged up with that and just walk around
the city
shooting shooting vomited people it
would be
you know just like like a really weird
superhero who's
it was so much fun i can't tell you it
was fun
now you have a daughter how old is your
dad i do she's four and a half
does she ever watch the show she used to
watch the show
when she was little now she's growing
she really figured it out and then she
started then it started to bother her
first it started to bother her when i
would have sex scenes with men and then
it
started to bother her when i would be
kissing men on screen and then it
started to bother her when i was
speaking to men on screen because she
knew where it was going so
right right i haven't shown it to her in
a while that's that's probably for the
best
now do you yourself watch a lot of
television are you a television person
um i love television i feel about
television the way i feel about candy i
love it i don't keep it in the house
see you so so i don't have i have a tv
set but i don't have reception
right right so you don't because i
noticed when you walked out here tonight
and shook my hand the crowd couldn't
hear me and you said it's nice to meet
you mr coppell
you like no but you don't you don't
watch a lot of television and you think
that it's
it's just for the best right you know i
love tv i watch so much television as a
child it's stored up i don't need to
watch
anymore because i got a tv i'll just
watch it all day
yeah well the other thing is it must be
weird for you because you're in the
entertainment business
you have this really hot show you go to
award shows because your show is always
up for awards yes
how do you know when other people that's
not wood um
it's a high density polymer i'm always
telling people there you go
uh the um
they just want to see me hit but if
you're out at these award shows how do
you know
it's very embarrassing who is like who
how are the famous person who's the
famous person
who's the handler who's the famous
person i i was at a uh
this the screen is screening the
premiere of the sopranos the second
season
and i complimented lorraine bronco's
daughter i said oh i love you on the
show and she was like i'm
i'm lorraine's daughter i'm not on the
show oh wow that's so cool
it's bad so now i just keep my mouth
shut i just say nice to meet you
you just have to always say to everybody
i admire your work because even if
you're talking to a plumber they're like
why thank you
i try just say i admire your work